and I'm probably pastrana me dot space
and you're watching our weekly
get-together with dr. Bryan Keating who
every week seems to have somebody new
and amazing to talk to and this week
we're going to talk about a about an
interview that Brian did with the first
author of a paper that you may have
heard something about in the news lately
about these there should be 36 I guess
alien civilizations in our galaxy and so
Brian does what he always does and he'd
nag he snagged a really good interview
and he's going to be here to talk about
it with us so let me bring him up hey
Brian how you doing it that's good great
yeah you put me in outer space where
these alien civilizations are looking
yeah that's right it's apparently
there's 36 of them looking at us so you
know what the heck is going on
what is this story about first of all
well you know we should probably
introduce everybody to you I'm sorry we
didn't do the thigh thing Bryan Keating
he's operate he operates his own YouTube
channel and he also has a podcast the
link to the full interview that we're
gonna be talking about it's in my
description box of this video we're also
streaming on his youtube channel dr.
Bryan Keating so follow him subscribe to
him do all the things and he also has a
podcast and all that so I want you do it
just a brief intro and again in case
people are watching they didn't see you
last week yeah 99% I don't know who I am
half the time I'm Bryan Keating I'm a
professor of physics and astronomy at UC
San Diego and beautiful Southern
California where we have not seen an
astronomical object in months because we
are suffering from June gloom you may be
familiar with May gray but we get June
gloom and it's threatening to go into
July we have not seen a celestial object
even the Sun weeks anyway so people
think of Southern California it's a
sunny destination but anyway when I'm
not busy doing cosmology or or doing the
advising do for my students
undergraduates and graduates I'm running
the arthur c clarke center for human
nations into the impossible podcast and
by virtue of my vast what we used to
call rolodex friends and colleagues in
the field I've gotten access to some of
the greatest minds in astronomy and in
and out of the straw man I've talked to
people in physics as well meaning
ranging from Stephen well friend that's
Eric Weinstein City Austin Felder and
many of the greatest minds in this past
week I contacted an old friend that I
knew when he was a graduate student at
the University of wisconsin-madison
where I spent a couple of years
finishing up my PhD and that was a
professor Chris consonance he is a
professor at University of Nottingham in
the UK he's originated American he's
been in the UK for decades now and he is
also involved with the Editorial Board
of the Astrophysical Journal so these
are entities that publish the most
widely read and important in terms of
impact journals in all of astronomy so
he took time out from his normal studies
of studying the evolution of galaxies to
do kind of a update to the Copernican
theory and update it to maybe make
predictions as to why we have not heard
from healing see we've talked a little
bit in the past about the Fermi paradox
which Enrico Fermi basically asked given
the likelihood for life and the
abundance of solar systems in the
universe even in the 40s and 50s when he
made this paradise so yet we have no
evidence conclusive or not that aliens
have been here in fact we have no
evidence so either way so the thought
was where are they basically summarize
there's basically we know a hundred
billion stars in the Milky Way galaxy if
each one of them had ten planets around
them more planetoids moons of other
planets then you would expect there to
be a truly impossible world where life
could theoretically humor so where are
they how come they're not here I think
Chris's explanation generated a lot of
attention because of its specificity
basically said you know the headlines
were
first of all the headlines in the UK
really funny talking you ever notice in
there like space boffins space boffins
say there are 36 civil is in there like
space boffins often but I guess it's
their way of saying herds yeah I really
good William Gibson book right now about
the main characters in the UK right now
and he calls a mirror world you know
from the United States just like mirror
world phone it rings just a little bit
different and you know the food's always
a little bit disliked yeah America and
the UK you really ought and and the
cultures are couldn't be further apart I
married someone from the UK I married my
Geordi and you'd think we'd have a lot
more in common than we do but there was
I mean culturally but it was so
different you know my I lived in the UK
for over a year and it was a real
eye-opening experience and of course
she's really adjusting to being here in
America so sure okay so you yeah so you
talked to this guy who's a friend of
yours and this is coming on the and as
you mentioned this was a this was paper
published in app Jay this is not just
any old Journal we're talking about here
this is the one of the premiere ones in
the U in the United States put up by the
American Astronomical Society and so
this is coming on the heels of another
paper that preceded it that also used a
similar statistical analysis that said
that that basically tried to distinguish
whether life was common or rare and
whether intelligence was common or rare
and we'll talk about that a little bit
more if we have time but this paper
seemed to raise a lot more eyebrows it
certainly did with me so why don't you
tell us a little bit about the research
and what these guys methodologies were
and what you thought of it so as I said
Chris is a galaxy's an
honest-to-goodness astronomer looking to
telescope through telescopes using big
honest-to-goodness that sounds like an
interesting qualified he's a
card-carrying member of a union called
the International Astronomical Union
he's a he's not
astronomer and most of what he does is
studied the properties of galaxies and I
think in so doing he decided on a
criterion within the Drake Equation so
let's take a step back the Drake
Equation is this governing equation that
that was proposed by Frank Drake in 1961
that had about seven or eight factors
that went into calculation that would
yield the probability and therefore and
eventually a number of intelligent alien
civilizations currently existing in the
Milky Way galaxy now so I point out
that's almost 60 years ago right so
we've had almost 60 years of the Drake
Equation and even before that people
were thinking about setting and you know
we did an interview with Paul Davies
about his book the eerie silence which
is written a decade ago and is still
pretty eerie we haven't heard anything
I talked to an Andorian Carl Sagan's
Widow and that episode be coming out
soon on the into the impossible podcast
but she basically feels like it's a
matter of time and we've only searched a
fraction of a drop of the ocean
equivalent but essentially he looked
they are very sanguine about this about
this phenomenon that you could in fact
make a calculation which would indicate
with some degree of accuracy what the
number of expected expected
civilizations would be in the Milky Way
galaxy
so his twist on it his improvement if
you will was I always say this and I
gave a [ __ ] at the SETI Institute so I
was on enemy territory because I was
talking about
why is Fermi paradox or sorry why the
Drake Equation is really kind of a poor
representation of what we astronomers
and physicists do the first thing you
remember this Tony from your
undergraduate days if you handed in an
equation and it just had an answer you
know it's a lab a lab result or
something and had no error bar no
uncertainty on it you probably would get
pretty poor marks as they say in the UK
right mm-hmm you would have been first
class and and I owe it you know if you
give a result in science and has no
uncertainty it has no meaning even if I
say you know Tony's IQ is as 200
and and I don't put any error bar you
may agree with that but but but if I
don't say with an uncertainty of plus or
minus 200 it changes very radically an
additional change the way that you
approach that the central value of that
number so the main headline was 36
civilizations in our galaxy in The
Guardian space boffins the equivalent of
the New York Post or whatever in London
and it was good fun but they never
mentioned there were very large error
bars that surrounded it and that's what
I wanted to get into it cress so I went
in deep in a discussion with him and I I
asked him first of all I asked him and
I'm glad I did because oftentimes you
know he's the professor he's a big shot
he's super well respected no feeling any
editor a major journal is incredibly
complex asking well who says call off
the tom is the first author on the paper
and it's also going to answer that
you're asked a question because you know
when we give a shout out to Tom not only
because you know he's the first author
and he was he was working with me but
also because the analysis that was done
is mainly a likelihood or probabilistic
analysis not an astronomical analysis
there's one little twist that crisp
added that makes it a more astronomical
than usual and that has to do with the
formation rate of stars in the in the
galaxies look you can talk about that
but most of the heavy lifting in this
paper was done by his boss at Tom and
and Tom's contribution was really deep
in probabilistic Tom must be his
probabilistic analyses according to
Chris made the papers results possible
and so I'll just tell you the the
headline should read there should be at
least 36 plus 175 minus 32 civilizations
within our galaxy this is called he
considers just a lower limit I really
want to talk to you phonies someday what
does it mean to have a lower than what
does this actually mean and so so how
does paper was done was was was thorough
it was methodical but the headline
that's being taken away is not
representative really of their main
inclusion which is in the error box
that's the thing that most gun
scientists don't realize it's really in
the elbow
yeah and I did I thought that the error
bars were large enough such that zero
was actually a possibility yeah you know
Ethan Siegel did a paper or did an
article on this paper and he mentioned
that where the error bar I couldn't get
to the paper because it's behind a
paywall so I couldn't read the paper
itself but yeah based on his analysis he
was saying that whenever you have error
bars that include zero where the
possible you have none that kind of
makes this whole thing that's right yeah
that's right probably I want to show you
see if this works this is live streaming
syrup this is kind of crazy I'm using
I'm using one of these LCD boards I
don't know if you can see it and then
I'm using an Apple pencil that's broken
so it doesn't work hey only about your
folks we exactly high-tech you know send
those patreon dollars to Tony so the way
that this should look talk about
distribution so you're familiar with
like a normal bell curve it was like it
has some maximum value let's say this is
this is height and this pizza I don't
know if I've put mine 5 to 10 in the US
for nails did you see this Tony buy the
round yeah we can we can see I just hold
it slow there's a call curve I'll try to
get the glare off yeah that's it just
worry about the glare that's poor so the
central value is the mean value that's
the most likely value that you predict
but this is not the only type of
distribution this is called a Gaussian
distribution and my artistic skills are
horrible but it should look like a bell
that's the famous bell cook so there's
some probability that you could find
somebody who's like 90 feet tall like
anyway off but the probability of that
is incredibly infinitesimally
exponentially small when inner hand
there's no one that could be less than
zero so it does have a hard cutoff at
zero feet tall now in the case of what
Chris and his colleagues are are showing
the curb instead of looking like a
perfectly symmetric Liberty Bell all
kind of shape would look like this
join the axes then I'll draw over here
at zero
and it would look more like this where
you have a peak roughly you know kind of
bell-shaped at the very top this is very
large number so this would be this would
be over 200 civilizations over here and
this is zero civilizations over here and
what they're showing is the most likely
one Sigma confidence bound encompasses
68 percent of the area of this curve up
is underneath in the you see that now
lift it up there you go yeah there we go
so there's 68% is between two hundred
and four that's 36 minus thirty-two so
so there's some non vanishing
probability that there are zero in fact
it's quite long to the probability that
there's zero is is probably you know
tens of percent or more and that's with
quality all of the you know optimistic
or realistic conditions that they put
into the Drake equations single term
really that revolves around the
probability for starters the form with
the proper property it's called
metallicity now you already thought
we're strange out there astronomers
because we consider anything that's
heavier than helium on the periodic
table of the elements we call that a
metal mama right Tony that's right yeah
and so so but now what he's saying is
that you can't have a civilization that
doesn't have metal email within it that
doesn't have that doesn't have a star or
a host star and it's stellar
neighborhood in the Milky Way galaxy
that has a large amount of available
metals and those metals would be then
used to make devices that could then
communicate with the earth so he focused
on his specialty which involves around
what we know about the metallicity and
how that traces to stars their form and
he also does an analysis that not every
star is equal as George Orwell said you
know everybody is equal but some are
more equal than others the most common
type of star in the solar in the end the
galaxy are these called M dwarfs and we
thought that according to him that even
though there's many many more M dwarfs
it was you're colder than the Sun
smaller than the Sun
they didn't think that those will be
very likely as hosts or planets that
could then maintain life and then that
life could become intelligent and then
that life could communicate that's the
that's the scene so he doesn't like my
SETI searching for extraterrestrial he
talks about communicating
extraterrestrial intelligent
civilizations penny so I know I've been
talking for a while you have any
questions for me well I just don't know
I just want to clarify some of the
assumptions that you may have gone into
this one of them was as I understand it
you've talked about the distribution of
what they found and what it looked like
but some of the assumptions were very
weird one of them being and correct me
if I'm wrong there was a weak case in a
strong case and the weak case was that
after five billion years of time
elapsing a civil as a it assumed around
sun-like stars with a planet like the
earth or an orbit around it have been
one year roughly earth-like then a
civilization must form that was the
assumption one of the assumptions and
the other one was that it would also be
once it formed it would have a
communicable lifespan of at least a
hundred years which is what we've been
doing roughly yeah those assumptions
seem problematic to me first of all
going back to that other paper I was
talking about they tried to estimate the
rarity or the commonality of not just
life but intelligent life the conclusion
of that paper was that intelligence is
probably rare they did was if the jury
was out on his analysis but it was
slightly less on the side of being rare
than being common and so here we have
two papers using roughly the same kind
of math coming up with conclusions in a
different way one of them says
intelligence is probably rare the other
one says we have 36 civilizations in the
galaxy and civilizations must form after
5 billion years for that to work to me
that seems like a problem do you do you
agree with that or yes oh that relates
to what we call priors so there's a
general class of how to calculate the
likelihood that a hypothesis or theory
of nature is correct based on a certain
amount of evidence and that evidence can
range from in this case is going to be
astronomical data it's going to rise
on certain types of of errors that you
might make mm-hmm and there may rest on
prior information that you've already
gathered so I showed this example before
when I was talking about when height or
weight or whatever we don't believe that
you can have less than zero height that
is a prior right I don't know if you
could really physically know contemplate
someone who's less than zero feet tall
but but imagine if people applied that
same prior to to enter or to as we think
about it in terms of charge that all
charges are positive you're imposing a
prior on top of your argument so
therefore it multiplies this
distribution it truncates it at a
certain value on the low end yes okay on
the low end now what he's doing there is
two things and the in the in the in the
assignment that you said he's putting on
a couple of priors on to this thing he's
saying that life has to last for at
least 100 years I mean it could be that
communicate for a hundred years it had
to be asset actively communicating and
so a lot of times you get your priors if
you only have one example you know the
famous Black Swan Nicholas natella if
you only have examples of white swans or
you know in your in your daily
experience you might say that all swans
are white until you have evidence
otherwise and so it's actually a good
approximation to do that but it's it's
susceptible to this confirmation bias
that you're gonna plug in things that
are familiar from your own experience or
local your locality so for this he's
claiming a hundred years is sort of a
typical lower limit and actually he's
saying it stars it actually would have
been more civilizations if he said that
stars that are only a billion years old
could form stars not so it's actually
making it more restrictive and smaller
by imposing a prior of about the age of
the Sun now I pointed the Sun is about
that age and again he's applying these
two priors and that's the so-called
strong kicks I think if you loosen it
then it relaxes and you get even more
civilization that's right yeah that's
right but you know what's so interesting
to me there's a colleague at University
of Rochester named Adam Frank who's a
Knopf
oh yeah I've had a hang out with him
once yeah cool yeah he wrote a book a
line of the stars and he goes through a
similar kind of cosmic Drake Equation
but he applies it to the whole universe
and he applies it over the history of
the universe and in the whole history of
the universe he claims there could have
been something like a lower limit or
even maybe the most probable value of
about 20 civilization so that sounds
pretty close to 36 except that there's a
hundred billion galaxies in the
observable universe so right he turns
out one I mean this yeah exactly so so I
think it's you know they're widely
wildin in violent disagreement one
another that's so I I didn't get a
chance to kind of actually I did ask him
it I don't think he read that book so I
didn't think it was fair to question him
on somebody else's book me but the
reason I think this paper got so much
attention was because of the
implications what would it mean if we
did say that there was a that there was
another civilization and in fact if one
were close by so how do we know that
they're not close by with Chris and his
colleague Tom did is go through and
calculate the expected expected distance
between these civilizations along with
some other more astronomical assumptions
so that these things that these plants
would have to be in the habitable zone
that they might not be surviving so
readily most of the stars in our galaxy
are near the galactic centers you know
but that's not as hospitable as being
out in the spiral arms and so there's
some there's some contention that they
argue for what would be the mean
separation in terms of light-years and
it turns out we'd have to wait a pretty
long time to get you know you know those
three dots that you see when you're
texting your wife and she's typing like
it would take 17 thousand years to go
from here to the next civilization
according to them again what's the first
thing you should ask me I just told you
the nearest SETI civilization is that
most seventeen thousand light-years away
it was at least I thought that was at
least it was the closest and most no
further closer than it so that's an
there's an upper limit to how far though
and what's your question what what
what's that mean what did you ask me I
just said I just gave you a number
seventeen thousand like this what's the
next question you should ask me oh god I
feel like I'm being tested
Oh the next the next question I should
ask you is what I don't know what kind
of star it was no no I really do talk
about that what did I say was the
problem with the 36 number that we keep
hearing about what's the main probably
the Guardian and all these magazines put
out they just said 36 they didn't say
what the Viera bars that entire bars
work exactly right so so what's the
should ask me what's the error bar on
that on that number Oh on the 17,000
number yes yeah hey hey Brian what's the
error bar good question on that number I
can't be taught it's plus 30 thousand or
so light years 33 thousand six hundred
light years and then it's - it could be
ten thousand light years closer so it
could be at seven thousand light years
all the way up to fifty like thousand
light years which is half the diameter
of the Milky Way so if you do think
about it in those terms in terms of
communication which they don't they
don't really get into there they're not
saying like how would you communicate
what would you transmit to them but
they're really taking like a star
formation galactic astronomers approach
using our best knowledge about the state
of a gap of galactic formation the stars
within a galaxy the lifetime of stars
how long do stripe stars live for and
what kinds of conditions namely
metallicity the fraction of materials
that are suitable that aren't in pure
gaseous hydrogen and helium form taking
those and applying it several different
criteria cuts to it to come up with this
number which again is very very large
uncertainty to it again with certain
pirates the priors are what they assumed
about the age of the stars having to be
above the age of the Sun roughly
approximately the age of the Sun and
there's an arrow bar on that - it's not
exactly five billion years or you can't
have a baby civilization so there's some
error bars
and then you go through and you turn a
crank you do you know what's called
Monte Carlo Markov chain oh I thought it
was Bonnie theater what's it more it was
Monte Carlo well that's one way to do it
they can do a Bayesian if it's analytic
and they can actually calculate the do
the integrals a lot of times it's even
if you're if you believe in the Bayesian
kind of hypothesis of evidence given
data and priors right but you still will
use a tool like a Monte Carlo Markov
chain oh okay
to analyze it this is just so many of
them out there and it's not like they're
testing the fundamentals of probability
and then the rest of the paper is is
cute it's a nice it doesn't require you
know advanced you know quantum mechanics
to understand it not I found a very
readable very enjoyable and the
conversation that I had Chris you know
go through a PowerPoint presentation
about kind of highlights of the talk and
it was really enjoyable so that's that's
on my podcast I think it's linked um
show you show notes in poly and my
channel and I put like I said I put the
link to the full interview are in the
description so you guys need to go watch
it and learn more about this since I
only have a limited time with Brian I
want to get a couple questions out my
first question to you and then I'm gonna
read some from the chat is what did you
think of all this what what's your
what's your opinion of the results and
this whole I thought for him because I
don't think you know first of all I
published the paper came out months ago
and I think it came out in in April I
remember seeing it earlier this year and
that true and and no on the archive oh
so when we saw the preprint server and
you can find it there it was submitted
in April yeah and I remember you know
breezing through it and really reading
it and feeling out that's kind of
interesting and it's a it's a cute it's
a cute and analysis that comes up with
some yeah I mean it's all talk yeah
that means fun cute used to describe
that's nitrogen with key results you
execute okay so so I really enjoyed you
know reading it and
I didn't make much of it until they came
out with this you know Guardian and I
showed this picture of him in a Turkish
newspaper and then like yeah the Sun
that's the daily Sun newspaper with the
space boffins and then they felt pretty
bad for because you know it's like
George Orwell said again another George
Orwell quote but he said you know donkey
has a magnificent tail but it's keep
away the Flies so you'd rather not have
the Flies in that he did say yeah what
kind of bad fun oh good well good I I
don't know what I think I haven't read
the paper unfortunate so I can't really
comment on it about the analysis and the
way it was done but you bring up good
points about the Arab arts that sounds
like it was more rigorous than I was led
to believe by some of the things that I
had read about it so that's good
I just wish and the reason I'm suspect
about I suspect all of this is that the
number didn't turn out to be 42 and I
think anybody who knows anything knows
that that's what it should have been so
I mean the only thing makes me kind of
going you know why 42 oh by the way not
just the Hitchhiker's Guide you know
what what's special about 42 times I
know to me it's always been Douglas
Adams but you tell me ya know it's the
most fortuitous Oh God come on people
come on what do you expect he's here all
week folks all right I want to respond a
little poor daddy's comment over 4,000
earth-like planets and only 36 shouldn't
that at least have a zero on the end and
maybe 360 most of the planets are
probably older than humanity and have
had much more time to evolve I just want
to point out something I the Kepler
space telescope had based on analysis
from what they've done the estimates are
that some percentage of small percentage
like ten percent or maybe less of this
of sun-like stars have an earth-like
planet around it depending on how you do
earth-like planet but of all of the
planets Kepler found it only found one
that was like the earth in terms of the
star orbital distance and things like
that
so out of all the stars that Kepler
and all the planets Kepler found one was
what it came out so this isn't so low
and I think I think you might expect
several billions planet Earth like
planets in the Milky Way based on that
research but he doesn't I don't know I
mean I I tend to believe the lower
numbers as far as these planets go what
do you think yeah well don't forget the
Kepler number is using a very special
technique you know application a subset
that's right and and those can only be
seen you know because Kepler lasted for
a few years and to accumulate enough
statistics you'd like to have multiple
orbits of the planet and even though the
planet so you watch Star Wars coming no
I've never seen never saw Star Wars of
which you speak okay so Star Wars so
remember how much older than Luke is how
its holder than Lucas who is Yoda
remember yahoo knows Yodas like it says
oh yeah how old is yoga oh I looked in
Tony's chat or my chat oh come on come
on Pete here come on Raj I know you can
answer up here I got Brian how old is
she oh de yeah just don't say when does
he say that in my way he says he's nice
he goes always nine hundred years so
he's nine hundred but what is that why
remember where is under what years yeah
rising far far away why do I know that
Earth you know how do they know what the
future my own counsel will I keep yes
yes I remember the line now yeah
princess got it John is off by Neil got
it yeah all these guys so why is Kepler
bias
why is Kepler the satellite is because
it's looking for things that are on an
earth-like time scale because the
satellite only lasted for what five six
seven years it did its mission for for
looking up stick and then ahead again
when we became k2 that's right yeah so
for four years it could count for at
most four earth-like years but what if
there was only you know the planet that
I was seeing
a ten-year long period or an eight-year
long it wouldn't detect it so because
they wouldn't transit and so yeah
ideally they said they wanted you're not
yeah so that Kepler year of a Kepler
number you know should be evaluated
something like again another lower limit
so what is a lower limit again the
height example can't be lower than it
can't be lower than zero so that's an
upper limit that's its lower limit you'd
like to have lower limits as an
experimentalist normally you have upper
limits right what's the upper limit on
the number of civilizations in our
galaxy there's probably not like
billions per per star so you know even
if there were you could say it's a
billion times a hundred billion so it
would give you a number it would be a
huge number that would be an upper
that's like saying you know my height is
under a thousand miles no so it's not
very useful but when you apply prior and
you have a lower limit and an upper
limit that means there's an answer
somewhere you may not be able to detect
it with present-day instrumentation for
example we know you've heard of
neutrinos I'm sure all your gossip
ratings you
we know neutrinos have mass we know
their mass can't be bigger than a
certain value but it also can't be
smaller than a certain value and maybe
we should talk about that something
neutrino oscillation neutrino mass
experiments and and how we go about
getting those but that tells me as it
cosmologist I don't have to build a
sensitive experiment to bring the lower
limit up in the upper limit down
eventually I'll get bingo pater so we
like to have lower limits and that's
what Chris's paper provides at least in
the assuming these assumptions are
correct right and they that's a
important qualifier Neil you wants to
know Brian what would your final number
be after refinements so I think I just
look at the prompt like this is gonna
sound stupid and again this is not my
field I am so far out of my lane I never
let that stop me I driving here right I
know
and I'll put a link in the chat that
myself any talk where I go through this
analysis I basically say the universe is
a certain age and there's certain number
of civilizations in the galaxy but
instead of trying to estimate the number
of civilizations or
we in the lack of them in the observable
universe or why they haven't come to us
the Fermi paradox let's do something
simple the Drake Equation applied to the
San Diego Zoo so how many people this is
four years ago in the zoo was open okay
how many people are in the zoo right now
and in this talk at the SETI Institute I
go through a calculation and it comes up
with like 10,000 but again what's the
first question you ask Tony
they're bars error bars they're bars
11,000 so it could be 0 or less than 0
and it could be 20,000 so it's not very
interesting on the other hand I think
about like what is the probability that
you can communicate and no one's ever
done this as far as I know how do you
actually compute the probability not of
the existence of planets with stars we I
believe Chris to do that is better than
me probably but look at all the steps in
the chain that lead to just
transportation just telecommunication
just the ability to transmit globally
into the universe and I also made that
point to Chris I said look we for the
first 50 years all of our signals were
scattered throughout the universe but
now we've deemed them we put them in
fiber optics we put them in laser pulses
we don't waste energy by broadcasting as
a monocle or radio or a dipole radiator
we've formed Gaussian beans to transmit
exactly the tony and nobody else could
we don't know waste energy and waste
waste money broadcasting scattershot so
I'd love to see an analysis is that a
thesis project for anybody out there who
is instructing look at the probability
to form the technology that we would
need look at all the steps that led up
to technology Maxwell's equations Hertz
dipoles just four radio waves and then
what happened before that you think that
Kurtz was writing by I I mean he
couldn't he wasn't writing by by
incandescent light bulb right I mean
Thomas Edison discovered the light bulb
without a light bulb you ever think
about that mm-hmm
so and then what was what was he using
he's using a candle you ask who's
working at night before that they used
whale blower you know and so what are
all the steps that have to kind of come
to shore the earth like we needed
petroleum to make oil to make the the
factories that then built the radio
transmitters in the internet right
that petroleum comes from microorganisms
that live billions of years ago what's
the probability that there's some energy
source I would say you can't build the
solar panel the first solar panel wasn't
built using solar electricity so how do
you make this technology if it's
ubiquitous what's the Drake Equation
applied purely to technology that's my
that's my homework assignment next week
yeah and to make it even more
interesting what if it is this the only
way it could have developed you have to
assume that this was the way well it
certainly was the way we did it but is
this the only way to do it and then that
opens up a whole different can of worms
with your assumptions so we needed
fossil fuels which needed all this
organic decay to happen first so you
look for planets that have a lot of that
in it so they can develop petroleum but
what if there's another way to get the
energy out in a different order so
that's the Freeman Dyson I said that you
know what we use whale oil so what's the
probability there are whales on you know
a planet on the constellation Andromeda
and you'd like smacked me across the
face but if anybody's interested I'm
serious if anybody is interested in like
doing a doing a project together with me
I'd love to do like a technology based
Drake Equation just for that what did it
take to get humanity into a point where
we were okay as Chris and its colleague
calls it ok Braj Luther wants to know
can current and future telescopes
confirm the number of civilizations can
we ever see these with current or even
future telescopes well I have a
colleague here Shelly right who's
building technology not to listen for
radio waves but to look for laser pulses
and you know again nobody knows what the
underlying priors or how many
civilizations might exist it's almost
you know it's a little bit above what
are called also attributed to Enrico
Fermi's he's firming problems where he
used to ask his class of physics
students how many piano tuners are there
in the city of Chicago right now and
they would have to like do these
estimation problems he guessed the
nation problems so a lot of the Drake
Equation is kind of predicated on such
in such analyses so technology could
hear it if we knew where was
looking at very sensitive receivers
radio receivers light detectors that can
see single photon pulses that can
amplify incredibly low signals but how
do we know what frequency they'll be
tuned in that you know well if I had to
guess the stream key for today and I
guess you know a thousand combinations a
second we wouldn't talk for a week right
I mean next is like a twenty six digit
you know I know I know it's like a
credit card number it's like so much I'm
actually we had a like we had a guess
what what we were gonna use each week
instead of relying on this lovely
streamcast technology okay well John
supple is asking what is that pad Brian
was using by the way by the way love the
book on the Apollo moon landing oh this
is called a boogie board not to be
confused with the surfboard reviews here
well not ten or eleven dollars on what's
cool is you can yeah you can press on
the erase button so I think Neil called
internet just sketch it's not an
exercise because you can erase its LCD
tablet it's about ten or twelve dollars
it is a battery it's the consummate
educating tool that's what it is
coffee fish is asking if dolphins were
equipped with arms and hands would they
be able to use fire as a tool just
wondering if they are intelligent enough
that's that question for a marine
biologist but yeah I would say they do
seem to use language they certainly
communicate with one another hunting
wise which is their number one you know
technology but it's really using that at
the location and so forth it's unclear
there are examples you know Jane Goodall
and others documented chimpanzees which
are the closest primates us that have
opposable thumbs they weren't making
fire but they were using sticks to get a
termites inside of them mouth and using
tools and and that requires very
complicated 3d modeling and spatial
relationships so that was very complex
and actually to build the first tools
like think about what went into building
a flint like the chopping tool like an
axe head it's a lot you should eat a
stone and then this
hominid how to think about well in the
future if I expend a lot of calories
which will expose me to being killed by
a saber-toothed tiger you know whatever
I can chip away and make an edge using
another thing blah blah blah and then I
can use that instead of using my teeth
to chop their bones and get the marrow
inside the box it's a very complicated
process so I don't think it's possible
with dolphins but but again that's a
good point that he's making that there
could be very well could be teeming with
life in the universe but not able to
communicate with us because they're not
technological yeah Neil you wants to
offer a I don't know about this man we
could shoot the Sun with pulses of laser
light and the aliens will see that no it
doesn't sound like a healthy thing to be
doing but no yeah but we as possible
yeah and he's commenting about exomoons
and things like that so yeah they could
ask him about that that's Chris about
exciting because you know we don't think
that life can exist in sac on Saturn but
Saturn has a moon called Enceladus and
people have thought about might have the
properties for now that's more like the
earth right it's a rocky planet with a
planetoid that's bigger than the moon of
the earth by far it's comparable to
mercury and it has an atmosphere so you
know theoretically these exomoons could
be basis for life to emerge not
necessarily the planets themselves at
Kepler can see you know they could be
sheltering that could be sheltering life
from like m-class dwarfs for example
which are very flurry and yeah and and
so you can maybe nestled in one of those
so yeah it's certainly a good place to
look better and better as common as
commenting I would think that any
hunting species would be able to develop
the intelligence and that it is only the
lack of manipulative skills Oh or their
environment that holds them back from
further advancement yeah I mean there's
a complex competition between the needs
of the individual the needs of the
civilization komasan is asking each at
age you know are we not answered from
moralizing and really assigning what's
another word for that Sony error is like
bias and and requires when you put a
prior on something you're reflecting a
predisposition which is okay to do
scientifically of course not in the real
world with people too
but but looking at at a you know bias
usually as I often say to get rid of a
bias like your thumb is on the scale as
you lay out how much coffee you're gonna
get you're gonna get less coffee but you
have to do another experiment to get rid
of the systematic error bias the other
experiment is the observation that your
thumb is pressing down on the scale then
you remove it you see you get zero when
you're zero coffee beans on for example
yeah but you know what I think about I
think biases are important to remove
definitely but when you're talking about
the numbers that we're talking about
here with the numbers of stars numbers
of galaxies numbers of planets and the
universe and possibilities I think even
with some pretty significant biases like
anthropomorphizing life in the universe
we're still gonna find it even with our
biases sure we can't believe that's the
only way that the only kind of life
that's out there we should remove the
bias and then start looking for others
but I think the biases don't get in the
way here these were you're trying to
find some non null answer right so
whether it's bias where it comes out is
right yeah where it does come out is is
in the context of communication so there
were some people that said you should
look for you should look for signals
what's called the waterhole which is
kind of a play on words because a lot of
animals and hominids you know
congregated in Africa on the savanna you
know near these watering holes but in
the context of astronomy it means the
one point for give your hertz line of
the hydrogen hydrogen transition between
two of its different quantum states and
hydrogens most abundant element in the
universe and it's makes up water which
is also extremely abundant as a molecule
and there's also water lines and so that
would be ubiquitous so you would look
for a signal to because the alien to say
every strong
is going to be looking and another
civilization is going to be looking at
the one point four gigahertz 21
centimeter Lawton so we're gonna put our
we are here on that on that frequency so
that we don't get missed
that's a huge bias right morphic bias
yes exactly but it's much better and it
you get a much bigger net with that than
you do by only looking for say episodes
of the Jackie Gleason show right I mean
you know you really aren't you know
that's really being biased and by saying
that you're looking at this this entire
frequency or spectrum yeah I think
you're still including quite a bit of
possibility there so my point is that
the biases don't necessarily hurt us so
much here when you get anthropomorphize
search you have to start so you're right
that's wrong and you're gonna find
something if it's there right in and
that's a good assumption to make you
know so okay well do you have to go or
do you have time for Michael yes I got a
couple questions on my stream okay go
for bout yeah over here we answered one
from kuma song let's see over here I
think Brian had a question it's all Sol
male or female just think about Tara and
guna I think you know Lunas a god I
don't know if Saul Sol is is a gender um
let's see
he also has dad jokes are an art thank
you very much I majored in the Arts and
Sciences
Brian asked could a super-earth exist
Arkham Asylum could a super-earth exist
in bother and I'm a stable of a dwarf
stock yeah if you remember there the
start of a star system called Travis the
trapper system about five or six years
ago actually one of my colleagues here
at UC San Diego Adam Berg a sir was part
of the discovery of that system I think
one of those stars is a red dwarf which
by the way I think I believe it was I
believe it was Jill tarter who's a
friend of ours who coined the term where
I do Worf
and as part of her PhD thesis at
Berkeley or maybe afterwards so yes they
do believe it it has certain properties
that make it attractive other properties
that make it less so some of these
things could be so cool that
the star would not provide enough solar
energy to do photosynthesis which might
think of as a prerequisite for life to
emerge a complex beam scale like some
stars are fake brian says because it
could be dyson sphere's that's true
that's the cap on it you can't roll that
out and then let's see yeah so those are
my questions are there any more on your
challenge that's okay just some comments
here yeah I mean see Mary NAR NAR Ian in
in it says commented that you're making
a lot of assumptions it's assuming the
aliens think like our astronomy
professors yeah you know but but my
point is it doesn't matter right you're
still gonna find something if the
numbers truly are the thing that we need
to worry about the sheer numbers so
surely there's something there when
you're talking about that big Annette
then your whatever assumptions you bring
in that net or is still gonna give you
something back
it won't be an accurate representation
because of the assumptions you've made
that's right much like oh yeah and and
the error bars with which you have but
you should find something I'm saying the
biases won't get in the way is what I'm
trying to the point I'm trying to make
anthropomorphize that's what andrew
planet was looking for when he was
looking for stuff about yoda and let's
see isn't the magnetosphere of jupiter
and saturn
doesn't it have too much for the moons
don't they get scoured by these fields
certainly on Jupiter and certainly the
inner moons of the cattle and moons I
think about that yeah I thought about
that well let's take a step back look at
Earth for a second look at your own
don't look at her so we know that
there's a South Pole in fact I've been
to the South Pole the cover of my book
is the South Pole and there's a North
Pole that's where Santa lives
and and those that there are two other
poles that you may be familiar with
there's actually a few bucks but let's
just stick with the other two more the
other two poles that you're familiar
with Tony the size means the magnetic
pulse so where are the magnetic poles
out of coincidence they're actually
fairly close to the geographically North
and South Poles one of my friends Robert
De Laurentiis has the channel called
flying through life he's flown around
the world
equatorially and now he's flying around
the world circumpolar and he already
reached a South Pole about five months
ago and he's gonna head for the North
Pole in a few months in his own plane
I'm Sophos and I mean everybody with him
on my channel soon but anyway he's also
going to go over the North Magnetic Pole
and maybe think the North Magnetic Pole
is very lucky it is closed for us that
it's close to the geographic pole why
because the geographic pole is frozen
over and inhospitable in fact there's no
continent there right there's no
continent at the North Pole South Pole
there is a continent and yet its sixth
if the cargo plane stopped flying to the
South Pole I would not be talking to you
I would have died long ago
because it's only accessible a few
months out of the year at the South Pole
so cold and planes can't fly there etc
itself now think about it if the
magnetic poles were close to the equator
where human life can flourish the
temperature being permissible for life
to exist but the magnetic poles were
there what also showers down upon the
earth at the magnetic poles cosmic rays
so it might be if the Magnetic Pole of
the earth was on the equator that we
wouldn't have much life on the equator
and life would be forced to go to the
northern and southern poles away from
the radiation belt that gets funneled
from cosmic radiation the aurora sort of
consoler accelerators so anyway I think
this is all just to say that we have
this incredible luck if you want or you
know another explanation this place that
put the geographic poles close to the
magnetic poles so that we could live and
not be bombarded our DNA would not be
completely alter than modified by this
awful cosmic radiation so just something
to think about even on earth it's almost
a
a happy accident that we don't live on a
planet like Uranus or another planet
where the poles are directed towards the
Sun and and they have their very
different properties from the hospitable
planet that we have on earth so
everything has to line up that's why I
think the most likely value I think
Chris grossly overestimated it yeah yeah
okay well rice has a good question I'll
ask what yeah you both think of sending
orbiters Rovers etc to Uranus Neptune
and their moons mmm while Rover is on
the surface wouldn't do much but on the
surface of the planet but on the moons
turn I think would be very interesting I
mean the promise that takes so long like
the New Horizons spacecraft was gnosis
yeah it took nine years you guys had en
I'm on the show because who now that was
incredible right but imagine how to slow
down an orbit around the planet
my planet Pluto a planet it would need
almost as much fuel as it took you know
not not the blast-off on earth but to
accelerate to 25,000 miles an hour
whatever was doing so it would require
tremendous technology that we just don't
have can we send micro Rovers there
perhaps but a very different phone later
or from the Sojourner and yeah so yeah
well it's great talking to you Tony yeah
okay what questions are we can I figure
I'm off and then let's let's connect
back in July I do want to turn people's
attention to kind of a different
podcasts that I did this week with Jim
Simon's who's called the world's
smartest billionaire he of course is the
patron behind the Simons Observatory
that I called lead with 300 of the
smartest people on planet Earth
and but he's also a mathematician who's
made foundational contributions to the
theory of what are called differential
forms and other objects and the last
thing I'll say about him is he's that I
think he's the Wando one of the most
growing a few scientists
and Eric Weinstein actually looks up to
so it's fun to have him on and I
actually asked Jim I said Jim do you
know this guy Eric Weinstein he has this
obsession with you guys I don't know and
I told him what he's interested in doing
is basically trying to get a Nobel Prize
for Jim Simons but anyway it was a it
was his first and probably only podcast
interview that he's ever done so I hope
people will tune into that a lot of
people have watched it he's an amazing
individual and that was this week next
week I have Adam riess a Nobel laureate
Adam riess video on Monday good one
really good one and then we should talk
about the conversation at with James
Beecham who's kind of arguing that we
have to spend twenty billion dollars or
more to build a next-generation particle
clock so I'd like to talk to you about
that time those videos on what particle
collider oh okay and a successor the
CERN that's four times through your dad
Wow
yeah let's do it man don't they have to
like let Switzerland know whenever they
turn that thing on they have to like say
hey we're getting ready to turn on this
Collider so I don't know how they're
going to power something that's even
more powerful than that oh they have to
call Switzerland the government we're
about to turn this thing on can you like
give us more power in Switzerland oh
okay we got it
okay well dr. Bryan Keating thank you
for joining me
we'll be back in two weeks it sounds
like go to Brian's Channel dr. Bryan
Keating youtube.com slash Brian dr.
Brian key you can see all of his but all
of his interviews here the one we're
talking about the link is in the
description box go listen to his podcast
subscribe to it did you ever get on
Spotify by the way are you still on
iTunes yeah yeah oh I think there's a
broken link in the description that
saying there's a gentleman okay I'll fix
it right now the one to the interview I
think okay Chris yeah it might have been
the copy-paste didn't work okay I will
I'll put it in and we'll fix it right
now thank you Brian you have a good
couple of weeks I work all the day next
week
I will say when we get back thanks
everybody
all right bye-bye okay so on behalf of